[SQUEAKING]
[RUSTLING]
[CLICKING]
ROBERT TOWNSEND: All right,
so let's get started.
Are there any questions
from last time?
So as you are no
doubt well aware,
this is the last lecture
I'm going to give.
The exam is a week from
yesterday, on Monday.
So what I want to do today
is to review the material
and see if there are questions.
So today, we're covering the
material from lectures 16
on, 16 through 21.
And normally, the exam
would cover 16 through 21
and I could have
written that in there.
I am just trying to
avoid confusion though
because the course is
cumulative and one thing
builds on another.
Essentially, it will
focus on 16 onwards,
but you should be,
by now, very familiar
with the early material.
And some of it may come up.
So this is just to prevent
me from misleading you.
If I said it was only on the
last one third of the class,
then you may get
lulled into thinking
that it's quite narrowly
about only those things,
as opposed to the things
on which it is building.
Anyway, just one word
of clarification.
And again, it's only
the third midterm.
It doesn't count anything
special in terms of your grade.
Let's see.
So last time, we
talked about money.
Bitcoin, in particular.
And I singled out two
questions, one of which
I kind of mentioned
in class, but let's
get you guys engaged in this.
A central banker, namely,
Dudley at New York Fed
is heard to say that
unlike Fiat money,
Bitcoin's positive
value in markets
is just a bubble and
with wild fluctuations.
So Bitcoin should be regulated,
if not banned altogether.
And then it says discuss this
statement using the tools
you have learned in the class.
So could I get some volunteers
to answer that question?
STUDENT: To be honest,
I'm pretty unsure,
but I do remember we
talked about how you can
have equilibrium with bubbles.
So they're not
inherently something
that you have to regulate.
It's possible to still have an
equilibrium, despite Bitcoin
being overvalued.
ROBERT TOWNSEND: Right.
That's true.
The question actually
asks about Fiat money,
I kind of slipped that in there.
That unlike Fiat money,
Bitcoin is just a bubble.
Can you maybe
respond to that part?
Maria, or anyone
else for that matter.
STUDENT: I mean, I guess
that is somewhat true,
as in it's not tied to a
tangible asset underlying it.
I'm not sure what exactly
you're looking for here though.
ROBERT TOWNSEND: OK.
Fiat money is a bubble.
It's a bubble the way that
Bitcoin is potentially
a bubble.
Fiat money used to
be backed by gold.
So there, if you didn't
want to hold the notes,
you could go to
the Federal Reserve
and demand a real commodity, so
then it would not potentially
be a bubble because it was just
a certificate for a commodity
that would have real value.
But when Nixon broke
the link to gold,
then Fiat money is
just pieces of paper
and nevertheless, it has value.
So the point of the lecture was
that Fiat money is a bubble.
Now we use the word "bubble" is
almost deliberately provocative
because it sounds bad.
But Dudley, who made the
statement seem to have not
let's say, forgotten-- seems
to have forgotten that his
domain--
Fiat money-- is potentially
fragile, as well.
Now, the difference
is the Federal Reserve
behaves itself, by and large--
or not to jump in with some
parenthetical comments on that,
but let's argue that
that's the case.
So then with forward
guidance and so on,
no one is expecting
high inflation,
which would lead to
speculations about how much
Fiat money is really
worth, and so on.
So whereas with Bitcoin, we
don't have a long history.
We haven't set
expectations, and so on.
So there are differences
between the two.
But in a model, it's pretty
hard to make a distinction
because they're both,
essentially, worthless
even though they have value.
So that's what I
was looking for.
The second question, should
currency pay interest?
Or more specifically,
what did we
learn in the lecture about that?
STUDENT: Is it related to the
non-zero price of a currency
because I remember
we say that cash
has positive value because
it can be used to pay taxes.
And that's a cash advance.
So if the price is
equal to 0, then nobody
will demand the currency, right?
ROBERT TOWNSEND: Yeah, you're
speaking to the levels.
So the point of having cash
in advance or taxes and so on
is that money would
always have value
because there's something
you need to do with it,
either buy stuff
or pay taxes in it.
This question interest
implies something
about how the price of
money is changing over time,
or that currency--
how can I put this--
the mechanical way
to bear interest,
even though you can't take
it necessarily to a bank
and exchange it
for more money is
to have the thing that
money exchanges against be
lowering in price.
In other words, a deflation
where the nominal price level
is going down means
that you can buy
more goods with money tomorrow
than you can buy with it today.
And that's effectively
like paying interest.
The way to remember
that is inflation
is bad, obviously, because
the purchasing power of money
is going down.
It takes more and more
money to buy goods.
With deflation, the purchasing
power of money is going up.
So that's effectively
a way to pay interest.
And what did we
learn in class about
whether or not it's
optimal to engineer that?
Any volunteers?
Yeah, sorry.
I know it's the end of the term
and you're all very, very busy.
So the answer was, in
that model of money
was spatially
separated agents, there
was a monetary equilibrium
with a constant price level,
but it was not Pareto Optimal.
And to get to one of the
Pareto Optimal allocations,
it was necessary to engineer
this kind of deflation.
So that's an example of
paying interest on money
is actually something the
Federal Reserve should
be doing.
I hope it's coming
back to you now.
Anyway, those were the
two main ingredients
of this very last
lecture on bubbles.
So I probably won't, if
history is any guide,
I won't have time to open up
lecture, this last lecture 21
and review it, but those were
the two principal components.
Namely, money as a bubble
and this policy aspect.
So again, the study guide should
help you prepare for the exam.
And now we're ready to
review the lectures.
There's only six of them.
So this material is probably
pretty fresh in your minds.
I think what I'll do rather than
obviously I wouldn't have time
anyway to go over all
the individual slides
of each lecture, I
will try to remind you
what we did and maybe
draw some connections
to the other lectures and how
things are kind of fitting
together.
So this was the lecture on the
fundamental welfare theorems,
namely, that
competitive equilibria
under certain assumptions
are Paretp Optimal.
And any optimum can be
supported with transfers.
So this lecture was about
sufficient assumptions
and the corresponding proofs.
And it ended with extensions to
more general commodity spaces.
So you may remember
that I did this.
I showed this-- back to
the earlier lectures,
the first part of the
course on risk sharing,
I showed the income
movements of households
over time and
compared to each other
and including the consumption,
we noted this gradient here
that the average
level of consumption
is increasing as one moves
from landless households
to larger landowners.
In the risk sharing
framework, that
was related to lambda,
the Pareto weight.
And very clearly, for
certain functional forms,
it was exactly that.
Pareto weight of one household
relative to the others.
But the motivation here was to
introduce the welfare theorems.
So then the issue was
whether the lambdas that
are implicit in that
diagram are related
to wealth, like landholdings
and the number of plow animals,
and so on.
So I was anticipating a
connection between lambdas
as in the Pareto problem of
Pareto Optimal allocations
versus the wealth
that may be needed
in a competitive equilibrium.
You'll see that again, or be
reminded of it momentarily.
So the first welfare theorem
is that any price equilibrium--
competitive equilibrium,
including a price equilibrium
with transfers is Pareto
Optimal under minimal sufficient
assumptions, namely
rational preferences--
which we haven't reviewed for
a while but it was in lecture
two--
complete transitive and
continuous preferences
and local non-satiation.
With those two assumptions,
we get this sufficient
for this theorem.
So this was a picture in
our familiar Edgeworth
box of a competitive equilibrium
being Pareto Optimal.
And the proof, you
may remember, relied
on starting with a given
allocation, the star allocation
and then conjuring up, by
contradiction, that there might
be something Pareto improving.
We prove this little Lemma, that
anything which is weekly better
has to cost us at least as much.
And then we just went
through the math,
summing up over
all the households.
Obviously, if it's strictly
better for some households
i prime, then it must
have costed more,
or otherwise, they
would have chose it.
So we get, in equation
one, the statement
about total expenditures, the
value of total expenditures
summing up.
All the households--
I'm going quickly now--
we used profit maximization.
We coupled equations one
and two to get a statement
about resource constraints.
And at the bottom
line, concluded
that this alternative Pareto
dominating allocation would not
be feasible in contradiction
to what we assumed.
So that was QED.
That was the end of the proof
of the first welfare theorem.
Now later, even today,
we'll review it.
This thing fails with if
these sums are infinite sums
and don't have finite value.
Then the second welfare
theorem was illustrated here
that we have Pareto Optimum
characterized by tangency
of indifference curves.
But that nevertheless,
it's not reachable
if we start from the
endowment and start
drawing potential budget lines
through the endowment point,
as you would for
candidate budget lines
in a competitive equilibrium.
So this was meant to
illustrate that to get
to this particular
Pareto Optimum that's
in the second welfare
theorem, we're
going to have to take some value
away from agent A over here
and give it to Agent B.
And that's what this said.
The tax on A is equal to the
subsidy on B. T being transfer,
so negative is a tax.
So then we could get, as in
the second welfare theorem,
to any allocation along
that contract curve where
the indifference curves are
tangent by reallocating wealth.
Now to prove it, we went through
this constructive argument.
We defined an economy.
And this slide, or
a version of it,
shows up at least three
times in these six lectures.
So an economy consisting
of preferences
endowments production sets
and profit shares here,
assuming a lot more.
Concavity and convexity in
preferences, production sets,
et cetera.
And then we get the
second welfare theorem,
that any Pareto Optimum
can be supported.
For some wealth, any of optimum
associated with some lambda
vector of maximized
weighted utilities
can be supported by a suitable
redistribution of wealth.
The way we prove this
was to go back to what
you know about Lagrangians.
So this was, I think,
also in the second lecture
of the class.
And you've used it
over and over again.
Maximizing concave
functions on convex
sets, generating all
the shadow prices.
So we used it here three times.
First we use it for
the Pareto problem.
So we're starting with a
Pareto Optimal allocation.
So we know, again, from things
you did earlier in the class,
when we introduced the
notion of Pareto optimality--
I don't remember
the lecture number--
we maximize weighted
sums of utilities,
lambda's being these weights,
subject to resource constraints
and production constraints.
That's all written down here.
The solution to any one
of these Pareto problems
is Pareto Optimal,
and all the Optima
can be described as
solutions for some Lambdas.
So we start thinking about
these so-called Pareto
problems as equivalent with
Pareto Optimal allocations.
Use the Lagrangian,
set it up this way
and get the first order
conditions, including
the primal, duel
feasibility on the shadow
prices, complementary,
slackness and all of that.
The point is that with all
that concavity and convexity as
appropriate, these first order
conditions from differentiating
the Lagrangian are not only
necessary, they're sufficient.
So any solution to these first
order conditions, allocations
and shadow prices that satisfy
the first order conditions will
be Pareto Optimal, will be a
solution to the Pareto problem.
So we did that.
Then we went to the second
part, reminded ourselves
of the definition of a
competitive equilibrium
with transfers.
Namely, consumer optimization,
firm maximization of profits,
and so on, along with a feasible
distribution of wealth, as I
was just saying.
So here's the second
and third time.
We're going to use the
Lagrangian for the consumer
optimization problem and
use it for the firm profit
maximization.
Here is the consumer
maximization problem.
Maximizing utility
subject to a budget,
we get this first
order condition.
And again, with a
concavity in the constraint
setting in the objective
function and convexity
in the constraint set, these
are not only necessary,
but they're sufficient
condition for an optimum.
All we need to do is find
the mu i at given prices, p,
and in Xi*, and it will be
maximizing for the consumer.
Likewise, for the
firm maximization,
we have necessary and
sufficient conditions
to find candidates for the
decentralized competitive
equilibrium.
And then all we did
was match them up.
Now I think the
tricky thing here
is to remember what
the given is and what
the objective function.
The given was a Pareto
Optimal allocation.
So for the consumer,
we started out
with these conditions, which
are the necessary and sufficient
conditions from the Pareto
problem being satisfied.
So we have the gamma sub L
for commodity L as a given.
The lambdas were
given because we
had a given certain
candidate, Pareto Optimum.
These were all satisfied.
We're looking for this thing.
We're trying to see if consumers
are going to be maximizing.
So the candidate
for the price would
be the Lagrange multiplier.
And the candidate for
the marginal utility
of income, the shadow price
and the budget constraint
would be one over lambda.
So here, I go back to
the slides of the Rocky
Mountain and Kansas.
This establishes a direct
relationship between the Pareto
weights and the Pareto problem
and the marginal utility
of wealth.
And hence, the level of wealth.
It's quite general.
It's super robust.
And so then the rest of this
was just the tedious part
of constructing the wealth, has
the evaluation of expenditure
and making sure that
they all add up.
We refer to this way
of finding the prices
from the second welfare theorem
as marginal utility pricing.
I mean, more accurately, it's
the lambda weighted margin
utilities which are equated
all over the households, not
the levels.
But when you take ratios across
different goods, L and K,
the marginal rates of--
the lambdas cancel out.
So the marginal
rates of substitution
are equated over
all the households,
as they are in this
picture, along this orange,
green, orange, green?
A yellow, orange line.
And this made the
wealth's add up.
And we did a second proof of
the welfare theorem, which
is namely one nuanced thing,
which is instead of just
maximizing utility
subject to budget,
we minimize expenditures
subject to achieving
a certain level of utility.
That conjured up this.
So this is the target
and different curve,
as it were, as if it were
coming from one consumer--
interesting comment.
But it's just the
aggregated better
than set associated with the
Pareto Optimal allocation.
The other part of this diagram
is two production functions,
different from each
other, but aggregated up
to an aggregated
production function.
And then you can see, as if
it were a Robinson Crusoe
representative consumer,
the optimum is characterized
by a maximal utility
level subject
to the single production set.
And then my point is that we
get this separating hyper-plane.
So all these definitions
supporting hyperplane,
et cetera, that's really
where given all the convexity,
that's all you need to do.
These convex sets are
separated from each other.
So this is a quite
general proof and it
works in many spaces, not just
finite dimensional Euclidean
spaces.
And we're about to review
the representative consumer,
as I said, this
looks all the world
like a representative consumer
because I've seemingly added up
the indifference curves.
But one should be aware
that it is not the Gorman
consumer that's going on here.
And this particular
Pareto Optimum
is sensitive to the
distribution of wealth.
You just can't see that.
I did not go through that when
I gave this lecture because we
hadn't gotten to Gorman and it
wouldn't have made any sense.
But I might as well say it
now, if you don't have a Gorman
representative consumer, then as
you increase this guy's budget
line and decreases
this one, you may
change the shape of this
seemingly aggregated
up in indifference curve
and, therefore, change
the whole optimal allocation.
So hopefully that
helps you think
about the hidden way
in which heterogeneity
is entering into this picture.
And this lecture, I finished
it off in an abstract way
by saying the proofs
of the welfare theorems
are quite general,
that does not require
a finite dimensional
commodity spaces.
I gave you the sufficient
assumptions for the two welfare
theorems and kind of quit there.
If we'd had more time, I could
have gone into greater detail.
I only asserted
without proving it
that if we took
what we did earlier
in the course
about Pareto Optima
with obstacles to
trade with incentive
constraints and potentially
non-convex consumption
sets because of
discrete choices,
we could nevertheless
introduce lotteries.
And that would have
turned the space
into a convex set and the
theorems, as in Debreu,
would apply to that.
So although this lecture just
proves the welfare theorems
carefully for finite
dimensional commodity spaces
and only asserted that
the theorems extend,
it would cover
competitive equilibria
in contract space
where households
can buy whatever
contracts they want,
granted at certain prices.
And firms as intermediaries
will create contracts
that maximize profits.
Tying some of the
loose ends together,
but without actually going
through much of the details
there.
So that was lecture 16.
Questions about 16?
So we'll come back to
it again because we're
going to go through
the failures,
or review them quickly.
Then this was the
existence lecture.
The point being
that, for example,
the first welfare
theorem assumes existence
of an equilibrium and
then assures everybody
that it would be optimal
under sufficient conditions.
But if the model could
be vacuous if there
is no competitive equilibrium.
So we're dealing
with things like that
directly in this lecture.
And this was a listing
of the things covered.
So the main mathematical
object tool really
was fixed point theorem,
this was an example
that some function has
across the 45 degree
line, in which case whatever
you put in, you get back out.
The argument in the
range is the argument
in the domain under
the function, F.
And it was sufficient
for this to have
the set of bases of values
in the domain and the range
being non-empty convex and
compact and for the function F
to be continuous.
And that's Brouwer's
Fixed Point Theorem.
I should say though, well, we're
about to get there, that this
is all about existence.
It's not about how to find it.
And at least one of you has
asked me questions about that.
Anyway, this is Brouwer's
Fixed Point Theorem.
It's paired with Kakutani's
And the way in
which they differed,
primarily, was not the
set A, which is still
compact and convex and
non-empty, but the function
F, which is no longer single,
necessarily single value.
It could be multiple values.
Or there are multiple
values in the range
for any particular
input x in the domain.
And of course, not
anything goes and had
to be convex value and
continuous in a certain sense.
And then with Kakutani,
again, we have a fixed point.
So these are very
powerful tools and they're
used for competitive equilibria
in one way or another
and used in games.
And we actually combined those
at the end of this lecture
to have a game that would
be achieved under a Nash
equilibrium as a
Walrasian equilibrium.
So here are what
happens if you don't
assume continuity of the
function, you get these jumps.
So if the aggregate
demand for an economy
somehow had jumps
like this, then you
could not be assured
that there would exist
a competitive equilibrium.
And we're looking for the
existence of prices, such
that you put prices in to each
of the agents maximization
problems, look at
their demands, see
if demands add up to supply.
And if we find the price
that makes that happen
and all of this can be
formulated as a fixed point.
Now I did not go
through the math of this
because it's
surprisingly tedious.
However, let me say that
the existence proof is
the existence of a competitive
equilibrium as in at least one
fixed point.
Herbert Scarfe did a lot
of work on this subject.
And in his proof of the
Walrasian equilibrium,
he actually did more, which
was to go back to Brouwer
and actually show how
to find the fixed point.
That is to say, in an
algorithm, take a guess,
look at directional derivatives,
formulate a new guess
and iterate until you get to the
end or approximately the end,
however close the
computer can make it.
And he would have constructively
found the Brouwer's fix point,
which works much more generally
than just finding the existence
of a competitive equilibrium.
This comes up later when we
talked about restrictions
on data having to
do with algorithms
and what the algorithms
actually look
like when computing solutions
to individual problems
and defining a
competitive equilibrium.
Anyway, I just wanted
to draw your attention
to the distinction
as an overview--
that's my job today--
between existence of a
competitive equilibrium
and how to find the competitive
equilibrium, algorithmically.
What we did do in
this lecture was
to prove the existence of a
competitive equilibrium using
the second welfare
theorem, which we just
reviewed in lecture 16.
So the idea is instead of
iterating on candidate prices
to find where supply
is equal to demand,
we iterate on these
lambda weights.
And the idea is
very much, here's
that economy again, I promised
you it would keep coming back.
The statement of the
economy with the convexity
and concavity.
The idea is to go back
to the Pareto problems,
this is now the
second time today
that the Pareto
problem has come up.
We just used it in 16 for
the second welfare theorem.
Here it is again,
stated rather succinctly
to remind us of these lambda i
weights, such that when we max,
we get Pareto Optimal.
So we start with
those lambdas and then
we essentially look
at the solution
to the Pareto
problem, these x hats,
for those particular lambdas.
Look at the prices, which
you now know and remember
are the shadow prices on
the resource constraints
and we generate the
wealth associating
with this purchasing power.
So what we're going to look
for to get a standard Walrasian
equilibrium his
particular lambdas,
such that the valuation of
privately owned resources
for a given household,
I, is equal to the wealth
coming from the lambdas.
Here this is a better
statement of it.
A particular lambda
star, the fixed point--
find me, please-- the fixed
point would be such that when
we substitute lambda into the
Pareto problem and generate
the optimal allocations, we'll
have some valuation at those
shadow prices of
the expenditures,
which when we sum up over--
and summed up over all
the commodities, L,
would be exactly equal
to the right hand
side of the budget, the
valuation of purchasing power
that the consumer has as a
result of owning the endowment
and getting shares in
the profits of the firms
when the firms are maximizing
at that same lambda star.
So this is the fixed point.
I think I mentioned in
a question and answer
at the beginning of lecture
18 when we reviewed 17,
that I felt I hadn't done a
good enough job explaining
the intuition for this mapping.
But it does come from the
second welfare theorem.
Start with a given guess about
the lambda that pins down
which particular Pareto Optimum
were targeting and suppose that
were the case that the
valuation of expenditure
at that optimum for consumer
I were strictly greater
than the valuation of his or
her privately owned resources.
Well in this case, we gave
this consumer too much.
They can't afford it.
So the obvious way to iterate--
if indeed you were
even searching--
is to reduce the lambda
for this household
and increase the
lambdas for the other.
So this is very much like
that Edgeworth Box diagram
for the second welfare theorem,
where I said household A has
to give up stuff.
This would be household
A if the inequality
is greater than or equal to.
And household B would
be the recipient
and be getting the transfers.
For household B, you'd be
under valuing evaluation
of the resources that the
assigned optimum could
be less than the valuation
of their privately
owned resources.
Now again, Negishi
didn't actually
show that one could
find the fixed
point by iterating
on the lambdas,
but in practice,
it typically works.
So as a numerical
algorithm, you could just
be trying out candidates,
lambda checking out
these kinds of budget
equations and so on.
So here again, this links up to
lambda equal marginal utility
of income.
That's the Kansas Rocky Mountain
pictures at the beginning
and I reinforce that when we
went to the second welfare
theorem.
So this proof of the
existence is working off
the same equivalence
between the lambda
and the inverse marginal
utility of wealth.
This is the computer
science part
that it looks like it
might be hard to find,
actually constructively.
So these guys
algorithmically want
to find the Walrasian
equilibrium,
not just be happy
with the notion
that there's a fixed
point so that it exists.
And this literature works on the
same, they kind of discovered,
again, Negishi.
So that's why I
told you about it.
But you get a better
sense here and I gave you
a hint of that, with respect
to Herb Scarf, that the way
to find it is to periodically
look at the aggregate demand
oracle, as it were, and take
a local derivative of it
to see which way
you ought to move.
So it's a little
bit harder than what
I said about just iterating
on Negishi's algorithm.
But their point is that they
designed an algorithm that
finds the competitive
equilibrium using Negishi
and it's not that
hard in the sense
that it's polynomial
of degree three
and the number of
goods, which is N.
So it's polynomial, rather
than exponentially hard.
So then we went to the second
part of the lecture, which
was Strategic Form Games.
This looks quite different.
You have utility
functions again,
but they can be a function
of other people's strategies,
not just your own.
Finite set of players,
that's kind of similar.
And we talked about
strategy profiles.
What household i is
doing, or trader i,
versus what all the
others are doing.
And we defined mixed
strategies, where the players
are randomizing, potentially,
over a finite set
of discrete actions.
So this is one place
in the course where,
again, these lotteries
come up to convexity
things in this case.
And indeed, the
convexification is
what allows us to prove
the existence of this mixed
strategy equilibrium.
A mixed strategy
equilibrium is a set
of randomization routines
for each player stacked up
in a vector, such
that given what
all the other players
"I" are doing,
minus "I", all the others.
But player "I" wants to do is
the I-star, signa-star vector
component of that vector,
better than any other component.
So this is the definition of
a mixed strategy equilibrium.
And then we had this
interesting side note here.
And this is a third
related, but not identical
statement, which is you have a
candidate for an equilibrium,
how do it really
is an equilibrium?
It's related to the
idea of the fixed point,
momentarily I'll show you that.
But here, the question
is, how many things do you
have to check at the candidate
mixed equilibrium Nash, mixed
strategy Nash equilibrium.
And it turns out you only
need to check pure strategy
deviations here, rather than
all possible mixed strategies.
Thank goodness because
that would be hard.
And the reason for
that is, if you
can find a degenerate
action which
dominates the supposed
mixed strategy
maximum, that's enough.
That's a particular
degenerate mixed strategy
to show that you
could do better.
And if there were multiple
ones that were doing better,
you pick the best
one that dominates
to break up the solution.
And if there were
two or more that
generated the same utility,
you could randomize over them,
but there's no need because they
all generate the same utility
so you might as well pick one.
So that's the
intuition for why it's
enough to look to
check a given candidate
profile against these degenerate
actions, not mix strategies.
The rest of it is remembering
exactly these kinds
of responses.
The better-than sets, or best
response sets for each player.
So given the others
are doing, you
want a best response
for player I, obviously
is going to maximize.
Hopefully, generating the same
mixed strategy as a candidate,
but maybe not, if it's not a
mixed strategy equilibrium.
But all the other guys
are doing the same.
So we're going to look for
a fixed point in the space
of best response strategies.
And the proof of the existence
of a strategy Nash equilibrium
had to do with the convexity
of these best responses,
as in Kakutani, for example.
In particular, all this stuff.
I'm a little worried
I'm going to get bogged
down in the weeds, but I did
want you to, on the other hand,
see the big picture.
So now we have two parts.
The Nash equilibrium
for strategic games
and the Walrasian equilibria,
they're all using fixed points,
but the economic problem
looks kind of different.
So I finished this lecture
off by drawing the connection,
like how do you actually set
up a market to find a Walrasian
equilibria.
And we did that with respect
to these limit order strategies
on the supply and demand
side and then wrote it down
as the game.
So once we wrote this
down as the game,
where players
decide what to bid,
given what others are bidding
it is a strategic form game
and we characterize
the equilibrium.
Turned out, you needed some
penalties, otherwise, they
would spend more than
they have and that
can't be consistent with
maximization-- well,
it would be maximization,
but there'd be no limit.
So it would not be consistent
with finding the Walrasian
equilibrium.
So we did have to find the
optimal penalty structure
in order to prove the
theorem that any Walrasian
equilibrium could be supported
as a mixed strategy equilibrium
in this market game.
And the other
direction is also true.
So that was lecture 17.
Are there any
questions about what
we were doing in lecture 17?
18 was aggregation.
And again, this is
getting more recent.
So hopefully, a little
more fresh in your minds.
We want to do this
positive and normative.
And I would say the
content of this lecture
is, what do we have to
assume, like it or not,
in order to be in
the land of macro,
where you have a
representative consumer?
And is usable in the sense
that what the representative
consumer would do, which from
a positive economic standpoint,
generate aggregate
demand as if you
had all the
underlying households,
but you don't need to do it.
You just use the
representative consumer.
So it's a very powerful tool.
But again, for you to decide
how strong or potentially
unrealistic are the
underlying assumptions
that allows us to do this?
So we reviewed the notion of
the indirect utility function,
which is the maximized
utility after solving
max utility subject to budget,
given the parameters, the price
and the wealth of a household.
And we quickly reviewed
some properties
of the indirect
utility functions.
In particular, Roy's
identity, which miraculously
says that if you
start differentiating
the indirect utility function
with respect to prices
and respect to wealth
and start taking ratios,
you'll get the
underlying demands.
And this was a tool.
And it's heavily used.
Again, now for the
third time, it just
came from the Lagrangian problem
for the individual household.
And Roy's identity
came from that.
And then we got to Gorman, which
is a particular representation
of these indirect
utility functions
as a function of
prices and wealth,
namely, this thing in six.
So it's separable, it has an
intercept of the function of p,
slope term on wealth
as a function of p.
I noted that the Cobb
Douglas would satisfy this.
We actually did the math.
This math is never
very hard to do,
as long as you remember that
when you have these Cobb
Douglas utility function,
these coefficients represent
expenditure shares.
So P1 times x1 is alpha
share of wealth, w--
likewise, p2x2 is 1 minus
alpha share of wealth, W,
for the second good.
So you can plop
them down right away
and just substitute into
the given utility function
and you end up with
this functional form.
I also noted that
although this is
special in that the
intercepts are 0,
it also seemingly assumed
that the coefficients, B, are
the same.
But no, this was a particular
indirect utility function
for a household--
a given household.
We have to start putting "I" in
the utility function to decide.
And if these alphas
were different
across different households, we
would need an alpha I on them
and then this thing, the
Gorman form, would be violated.
So the first part of the
positive representative
consumer was just saying a
definition of aggregate demand,
namely, it's the
sum of the demands
over all the individual
households at price vector, p,
and Wealth's WI.
And the Gorman part is
to find that demand--
this guy here-- depends
on the vector of wealth's
in a particular way.
Namely, it's just
the sum of them.
Or in other words, it's enough.
We should be able to
find a utility function
and give this mythical
representative household all
the wealth in the economy and
have that household maximize
utility, generating
aggregate demand, which
would be the sum of
the individual demands
if we'd bothered to keep
track of the micro economy
and the individual
wealth levels.
So this statement was
necessary, but it's
about to be sufficient if the
individual households have
this particular indirect
utility function of the Gorman
form with the I only on
the A intercept piece,
although w depends on I,
but that's because it's
individual households wealth.
Then the utility
function we're looking
for is just going to be
an aggregated version,
aggregating up the
intercept terms
and imposing the same
coefficient on the wealth
across all the households.
Now do you like it or not?
It is going to require that
we have these linear expansion
paths, if we go back
to the micro economy
and see how they're behaving.
But giving wealth
to one guy would
increase utility and consumption
in exactly the same way
that consumption would be
decreased for the other one.
So moving wealth around because
the slopes of these lines
are the same, they're
parallel lines,
moving wealth's around has no
effect on aggregate demand.
It's a restatement
of the positive part
of the representative consumer.
If you're listening
to macro economists,
worried a lot about
marginal propensity
to consume out of wealth
and out of transfers.
They're trying to find transfers
to particular constrained
households in a
way that they would
eat a lot as if there was a
special virtue of pumping up
aggregate demand.
Well they don't
have Gorman in mind
because aggregate demand is not
determined by the distribution
of wealth under Gorman.
It's determined by
the aggregate wealth.
So it wouldn't matter who
you gave the money to,
if it were Gorman world.
Positive representative
consumer.
The proof of it I'm not
going to go through.
It's basically using Roy's
identity over and over again
and exploiting the linearity.
Adding up and then
taking it back down.
There's examples of Gorman
aggregate preferences,
allowing variation
in the intercepts.
So households do not
have to be all alike.
And the normative
household, normative
in addition to being positive,
there's another definition,
namely we're looking--
we have the underlying micro
economy with the heterogeneity
across all the households.
We're looking for this
fictitious utility function,
U*, which we label the utility
function of the normative
representative household
to satisfy two properties.
Namely, if we want to see if
something x and y is Pareto
Optimal, then we can search
for alternative allocations
that might Pareto dominate.
In the normal micro land of
all these different households,
you have to check out
each and every one
to see if they're better off
under the proposed alternative.
With Gorman normative,
you don't have to do that.
You just sum up all the
demands in the baseline
and in the alternative and
evaluate that sum under this
mythical utility function, U*.
So if something predominates,
then it has to have a higher
return under U*.
So that makes the search
a whole lot easier.
And the flip-side is the same
with an important caveat.
We start with a baseline and
you find a prime allocation,
which is dominant under
U*, after you sum up.
Then we should be
able to do better.
So there is a way
in the micro space
to assign allocations
that add up
to the prime bundle
that are not necessarily
the actual prime allocation.
A way to do that in such a way
that everyone is at least as
well off and some
people are better off.
So the point of this is, it's
very strong when it works,
it's a way of
evaluating allocations.
But is it is not to say
that you don't have to worry
about the distribution.
You could make
people better off,
as I've said
before, I think when
I gave this lecture, free trade
could make everyone better off.
But you shouldn't stop there
because even under Gorman, you
have to redistribute wealth
in such a way as to let it
Pareto dominate the
tariff equilibrium.
Maybe that's a less that
trade theorists kind of forgot
to emphasize
So we did this in--
we actually did the proof in
the space of indirect utilities.
And again, I don't want to
go through that too much.
So at the end, we
have the application
of those positive and normative
representative consumers
to this slide.
This is the third time that
I've shown you this economy.
And at least maybe
the third time,
we talked about the Pareto
problem in this economy.
This Pareto problem, of
course, has the lambda weights,
as well it should.
But if we have a positive
and normative representative
consumer, then amazingly, we
can drop the Pareto weights
and just maximize U*.
So it's as if there's
a single representative
consumer with an aggregated
production technology,
like Robinson Crusoe.
And this is a much, much
easier problem to solve.
Hence the power of it for
macro because we're solving it
in the space of macros.
And again, typically,
people forget
to think about the underlying
distribution and the underlying
wealth distribution
of welfare gains
and maybe even losses so
stick with the aggregates.
So are there any questions
about lecture 18?
19 went the other direction.
And I paired them deliberately.
Instead of saying, look
at all the special things
you can do if you assume
special structure,
like linear income
expansion paths,
let's try to avoid any
restrictions whatsoever
on utility and production
sets and so on and still see
whether we can say
anything at all.
So the spirit of this
is very different
from the previous lecture.
And this is about not
assuming Gorman aggregation,
or not even assuming anything
much at all about expansion.
Could have given goods.
What, if anything, can
we say or given data,
can we just always accept
that there's an economy that
would have generated the data.
And we've talked about
this at the beginning
of the following class.
So we want to put as little
structure as possible.
And we did this a couple of
ways with an infinite amount
of data, with a
finite amount of data.
We did it in partial equilibrium
under consumer choice
and then we made
some connections
to general equilibrium theory.
The Slutsky thing
came from a property,
namely, that we
minimized the expenditure
necessary to achieve a
certain level of utility.
That expenditure
function is concave.
And then the derivative of
the expenditure function--
a bit like Roy's
identity, not quite--
is the hexane demands.
So the second derivative of the
expenditure function, a matrix,
really of cross
partial derivatives
has to be symmetric and
negative semi-definite.
This statement is what led
to the Slutsky equation.
This is a version
of that equation.
I guess for the purposes
of the lecture in terms
of what's the point of it all,
one is we get restrictions
from the data.
Assuming preferences
are regular,
we get restrictions on
something we never see.
Namely, these compensated
Hicksian demand functions,
as I think we went
through in lecture 3.
But fortunately, we're able
to write out the left hand
side, these Slutsky derivative,
cross partial derivatives,
in terms of observables
on the right hand
side, which are directly from
the consumers optimization
problem.
How demand changes with prices,
how demands change with wealth.
And of course, we
would be observing
the actual allocations.
This is with infinite data.
So again, we're
allowed conceptually
to think about having
all these derivatives
for infinitesimally small
changes available to us.
And again, as I went through
in class from lecture 3,
when we did the income
and substitution effects
we had written with the
S on the right hand side
and DXDP on the left hand side.
So there was a negative sign.
But it's all the same.
It's all equivalent.
So then we're saying
Slutsky would be satisfied
and a couple of other
things are satisfied
if we have the premise of an
underlying rational consumer
maximizing utility.
And we reviewed this
in the discussion
of the subsequence class.
We have homogeneity of
degree 0, and Walras law.
Spending your budget, no
price solution and spending
and being on the budget
line that plus Slutsky are
the restrictions implied by
having a utility maximizing
rational household.
And it turned out that it
goes the other way, as well.
That is to say, if you had
data that satisfied these three
properties, then there would be
an underlying utility function
that's quasi-concave
increasing and so on that
would have generated the data.
So this seemingly bears
some similarity to Gorman
in the sense of could we
generate the aggregate demand
by maximizing a
utility function?
Could we find the
utility function, U*,
such that given the
household all the wealth,
the solution to that problem
would be the underlying
demands.
Here though, we're giving
the data, including demands,
for a given household and
trying to find whether or not
there exists a utility function
that will generate demands
with all these properties.
And the answer
is, yes, that it's
sufficient and necessary
to have these properties.
So the theory has
content, you just
need to scroll through
this list in the data
and see if you can
violate one of them.
And it could not have come
from a maximizing household.
Convexity was not testable,
not with this demand theory
because you generate
the same data
and we actually made a
connection to computer science.
So this part, this is
testing with finite data,
not an infinite amount of data.
And the key here was
the beginning, at least,
this Weak Axiom of
revealed preference, which
you should all know--
and again, we reviewed it
in the subsequence lecture
at the beginning--
that pairwise, if we have two
observations prices and demands
and situation one and
situation two, then a price P2,
if they're observed choosing
X2, it better be the case.
And X1 was available
and not chosen,
it better be the
case that it price
is P1, where
they're choosing X1,
they don't have X2 available.
Otherwise, they were
supposed to have chosen it.
If it had been
interior in the budget,
according to the
first statement,
it would be utility maximizing.
So this is putting
restrictions on data.
The Weak Axiom
Revealed Preference
is looking at
pairwise observations
as we move prices and demands
around to see if it's quote,
"rational".
Weak Axiom of
Revealed Preference.
And then we generalize that.
We call those Directly Revealed
Preferred pairwise comparisons.
And then we went on to talk
about Indirectly Revealed
Preferred, or just
Revealed Preferred.
And the content of
this was, we never see
all the pairwise comparisons.
We never see XT
directly compared to XS,
but we do see it
indirectly because we
have XT, in this case, Reveal
Directly Preferred to XR1,
XR1 reveal preferred to XR2.
And so on down the chain.
So under one of those properties
of a rational consumer,
namely transitivity, if we had
a sequence of Reveal Directly
Preferred and under
transitivity, XT
should be revealed preferred,
directly preferred to XS too.
So when you can do the
pairwise comparison, a TNS,
it better be the case
they don't violate
that XT is preferred to--
weakly preferred XS.
So this second part is, assuming
underlying consumer rationality
in order to set up a situation
where we can actually
impose the test.
Then we did that in
computational economics,
which I mentioned I elaborated
on in the subsequence lecture.
And we took it to
general equilibrium.
So are there any questions
about risk sharing?
Any questions about lecture 19?
These reviews get
faster and faster
as we approach the
end of the hour.
But on the other hand, it's
more and more recent, so
not so worried.
21, we already did.
So that just leaves us with 20.
And 20 is pretty familiar, which
was the failure of the welfare
theorem.
So we kind of covered
sufficient assumptions already.
And then for the fourth--
third or fourth time--
I'm showing you this economy
again in all of its glory,
with the convexity and concavity
in the appropriate spots.
Statement of the
second welfare theorem,
you actually saw this slide
before in the review today.
And the second
welfare theorem says
that any Pareto Optimum
can be supported
as of Walrasian equilibrium.
So here's a case where
everything's working out fine.
There is a Pareto
Optimum, obviously.
This is the supporting
hyperplane, again.
So it's going to be a
competitive equilibrium.
But the second welfare theorem
has sufficient assumptions
to convexity.
So as I said, I
think last time--
or in answer to this
second to last time--
the starting point
here is something
that's Pareto Optimal.
And it's easy to lose track of
the direction of the argument.
Is this Pareto Optimal?
Yes, it certainly is, or at
least you can imagine so.
This is the indifference
curve that's tangent, locally.
And you could try to move
away from there, globally.
But whatever you
do, it has to be
on this production
set to be feasible
and that's going to be
associated with a lower
level of an indifference curve.
So this is the best
level of utility
achievable within and on the
production set, and likewise
over here.
Oh, but then the
second, I'm forgetting
the second part of the theorem
is, can it be supported
as a competitive equilibrium?
And the answer is
no because given
this imagine
supporting hyperplane,
the household
would be better off
moving away to some extreme.
Have a higher utility.
So it's not going to be
consistent with utility
maximization.
And this one is not consistent
with profit maximization,
even though it is still
a Pareto Optimal point.
As you could
construct, graphically.
So I showed you this
picture earlier.
This is kind of an
aggregated version of it.
It says those assumptions
are sufficient,
they're not
necessarily necessary.
The first welfare theorem
as a competitive equilibrium
is optimal.
This one assumes the existence
of a competitive equilibrium.
All we need is rationality
and non-satiation.
But this was a picture
showing that if we
don't have
non-satiation locally,
we're not necessarily
going to show
that the competitive equilibrium
is Pareto Optimal because we're
given the competitive
equilibrium we can find
something Pareto dominating.
Then we went through
this pollution example,
which is not allowing
trade in all the goods.
And again, the intuition for
this miraculous price system
when it works means
that households only
have to evaluate things on
the margin at those prices.
They internalize
through the prices
and make the right decision.
The prices reflect
the social trade off
of increasing or
decreasing demands.
And of course,
they're much aware
of their utility consequences,
their marginal rate
of substitution.
So if we get it right in
a competitive equilibrium
in complete markets, and
the price system conveys
all the right
things on the margin
and all the people have to do is
take from God this price system
from Adam Smith, you might say,
as if by an invisible hand,
namely, the price system
be guided to Pareto Optimal
allocations.
But likewise, if we
screw up the markets,
then the whole
thing falls apart.
And the solution
example was where
we didn't have a price
for all the goods,
so we don't have a rate
of substitution of one
good for the other in the
market and households and firms
make efficient choices.
So we did that with the
pollution as a leading example.
We went to arrow
to generalize it,
where households care
about other's consumption--
either they're
altruistic or envious.
And the same thing
kind of works.
This is the fourth
or fifth time today
that we talk about
a Pareto problem
and associated first
order condition generating
shadow prices.
So we're following
exactly the same steps as
in the second welfare
theorem and finding
a way, despite the externalities
and utility functions,
to support the Pareto
Optimal allocation
as a competitive equilibrium.
We already talked about
failure when we have
an infinite number of goods.
This was an example of how to
Pareto dominate an allocation
by, essentially, giving the
first household some goods
the second had and then the
third giving to the second,
and so on.
This is exactly what's going on
in the overlapping generations,
monetary economy of lecture 21.
Money is worthless.
It's just pieces of paper.
There's no intrinsic value, but
if household two here came up
with money and gave it to
household-- took money, sorry,
from household one and
exchanged it for goods,
then one gets the goods and
two gets the money and then two
can pass the money along
to household three.
So there is a connection
between this artificial example
and the fact that we get a
non-optimal autarky equilibrium
dominated by a monetary
equilibrium in the overlapping
generations model, which we
talked about at the beginning
of class.
OK.
So essentially, that
was it for lecture 23.
And we already
reviewed lecture 21.
So questions?
I enjoyed teaching the class.
I really enjoyed the
interaction with you guys.
You're really doing well.
It's a great joy to me.
I hope you like this way
of learning economics
and you're really
quite well trained now.
Thank you very much.